[Music]
hello there welcome back I'm glad you
could join me today let's just dive
right in and run all the colors across
the screen that you'll need to paint
along with me I have my regular old
canvas here wet and ready to go now
let's grab our trusty two-inch brush
here whack that off a little bit just
beat it like it owes you money we're
gonna get a little dab of our yellow
snow here mix that with just another
little dab of our baby water now well
that's just dancin happy little sky
remember this is your world you get to
make and break the rules here sweet baby
Jesus
wish I could jump in there and roll
around and all that cascading white
powder yeah just get high and all of
life's splendor god I love cocaine so
much holy [ __ ] knuckles I am high as a
kite right now okay let's paint in a few
little happy trees there nothing wrong
with making friends with trees no what
you don't want to do is eat these paints
trust me on this one all right I'm gonna
walk off from Ken that's right that
feels good
[Laughter]
would you look at that it seems like we
have ourselves a finished painting so
from our family to yours keep your pants
dry your dreams went and remember hugs
not drugs
[Music]
hey everybody Deadpool - teaser let's
break it down so if you don't know what
wet-on-wet means that's actually a
watercolour painting technique so a lot
of this is a parody of Bob Ross with a
whole bunch of references stuck in in
the names and the stuff that he's
talking about
along with real footage from Deadpool -
and our first look at cable right at the
end he was that crazy cybernetic hand
reaching for all the gun parts so let's
break this down if you're finding me for
the first time - be sure to subscribe to
get everything I'm doing special
giveaway stuff that I'll explain at the
end of the video but starting at the
beginning so if you didn't know
obviously all the footage is references
to something else like there's a whole
bunch of stuff packed in here but the
actual video description is an easter
egg - so it reads after surviving a
near-fatal bovine attack a disfigured
cafeteria chef Wade Wilson struggles to
fulfill his dream of becoming Mayberry's
hottest bartender while also learning to
cope with his lost sense of taste
searching to regain his spice for life
as well as a flux capacitor Wade must
battle ninjas the Yakuza in a pack of
sexually aggressive canines as he
journeys around the world to discover
the importance of family friendship in
flavor finding a new taste for adventure
and earning the coveted coffee mug of
world's best lover so that's sort of
their funny way of telling you what the
movie is actually gonna be about like
disfigured cafeteria chef Mayberry is
from Andy Griffith they are actually
kind of honest with some of the
description - not all of it's just a
total joke like the Yakuza ninja
sexually aggressive canine is talking
about all the people he'll be fighting
so it sounds like he might actually be
going to Japan during the movie at some
point but it does say that he journeys
around the world so it sounds like we
might go more than one place around the
world getting to the actual footage
though there's a whole bunch of movie
references and references to people
places things
first there's the indigo girls band
Soylent Green it's made of people men in
black the movie box office gold because
Deadpool one made a [ __ ] ton of money at
the box office
Doc Brown from Back to the Future
pretty-in-pink the movie he says whack
this off like it owes you money
silver licious is
children's book yellow snow should be
obvious don't eat the yellow snow but
then he says yellow snow mixed with
Betty White so I guess somebody's taking
a piss on Betty White there's a reddit
reference then there's a jump cut from
this yellow sky he's painting to like a
completely winter mountain landscape so
obviously he's making a joke about doing
a lot of cocaine but I thought this
might actually be a backdoor reference
to them dropping more footage this
Christmas but like at the end of the
teasers they have the Thanksgiving
spread of like all the main cast members
that might actually be when they're
dropping the next trailer just like the
idea that they're dropping a trailer at
Thanksgiving but I just love that quote
wish I could just jump in there and get
high on all this white powder the reason
why he's making so many jokes about
cocaine is there's a lot of conspiracy
theories about the artist Bob Ross who
starred in all these painting videos
people thought that he just did a ton of
drugs then it jumps to a cabin in the
forest he says he's gonna whack off
again then it sees a creepy bird picture
flips out and it jumps to regular
footage from the actual movie so this is
Deadpool pulling his gun out maybe he's
fighting Yakuza like I said in the video
description this is another Weapon X
type facility it looks like there's a
bunch of containers with people that he
might be trying to free that's getting
blown up this is Deadpool without his
costume going after someone he jumps
down on to a car probably from like
really high up on a building and then
rams into a car this is actually the kid
from hunt for the will Drupal Julian
Dennison you may have seen the
announcement when they cast him in the
movie it looks like he's a mutant and
he's the one that's starting this fire
it looks like some sort of rally Center
because there's all these banners in the
background that are trying to incite
people against people who are not pure
beloved maybe there are organizations
that hate mutants so they're going after
them because they're not what you would
call pure blood but they haven't
released which character he's playing so
there are a number of people with
pyrokinesis in the x-men comics there's
Wiccan Sun fire pyro
you remember the pyro was actually a
character during x-men Last Stand so he
could be a recast version of that
character but I think it's more likely
that he's playing a different character
like Wiccan or Sun Fire we'll probably
find out pretty soon but you get your
first look at za z beats is Domino
you see him with Vanessa at home
dopinder is back negasonic teenage
warhead is also back giving him the bird
it looks like there's this Weapon X
shipping container behind them like
they've stopped it or saved a bunch of
people you also see it here like it's
getting ready to crash Deadpool in blind
al who is also back of course
weasels back and then Deadpool doing a
hit on someone at a funeral disguising
himself as the body this looks like him
juggling a chainsaw during a hit like
he's doing something funny while he's
taking someone down this just looks like
it's him cooking some sausages nothing
really special about this but then he
goes back to the bob ross thanksgiving
spread with cable the rest of the cast
keep your dreams dry in your pants wet
and then it just goes through a whole
list of credits that are a bunch of
funny references so there's Ross Bob art
for Bob Ross art Jerrica Benton lead
singer is Jem Jem is truly outrageous
shout out to chief engineer Geordi
LaForge from Star Trek Blanche is from
Golden Girls just like Betty White maybe
you remember Teddy Ruxpin I think I had
one of those when I was a little kid the
camera 1 camera 2 is a Wayne's World
joke where he goes camera 1 camera 2 is
he's staring at his girlfriend lighting
by Thomas Edison Dalton was a famous
scientist who developed modern atomic
theory so when it says security like he
was the person in the chain of events
that led to the creation of the atomic
bomb that was Oppenheimer who developed
that though everybody remembers boom
goes the dynamite Chim Chim the grip is
actually a reference for the monkey from
speed racer' the bug and parker is from
a Reading Rainbow children's book and
then like I said before the hand at the
end grabbing all those different gun
parts is cable that's just his
cybernetic hand so the obvious reference
to make is is that they're trying to
tell you when the actual trailer is
dropping because this is just being
called wet-on-wet teaser meaning that
there is an actual trailer that they
will drop before the end of the year so
my guess is is these are just leading up
to a Thanksgiving reveal and then
they'll do something again this winter
because of that winter wonderland
obviously also a reference to him doing
a bunch of coke but let me know what you
guys think of this in the comments below
and if there are any references that you
spotted that I missed
write them below in the comments but
what will happen is is I'm gonna post my
Justice League review video next that
should be up in a couple hours so I'll
announce the next I max take a giveaway
winner when I post that there's just
like a whole bunch of movies coming out
between Star Wars Justice League so I'm
just giving away generic gift
certificates and you guys can use it for
whatever movie you want so while you
wait for everything you can click here
for more Deadpool 2 videos and you can
click here for my Thor Ragnarok
alternate post-credits scene video
deleted scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight